the announcement came on Friday that NFL
teams may reopen facilities beginning on
May 19 and the key aspect the key factor
they have to be permitted to do so under
governing state and local regulations
this has created a situation where some
teams will be able to open and some
teams will not be able to open it
depends upon what state you're in the
Giants for example will not be able to
open presumably the Jets won't be able
to open either but the Falcons are
opening on Tuesday the Cardinals will be
opening the Broncos are gonna have some
employees come back next week it's a
phase one plan and the thing that the
NFL has done to balance out the
potential competitive disadvantage Chris
no coaches can return no coaches
other employees only no players
obviously that's still to come as they
work out a plan with the NFL Players
Association but coaches are barred and
that also applies to Bill O'Brien even
though he's also the general manager of
the Houston Texans the league clarified
that point for me on Friday night so
some teams opening up because they can
in the areas where it's permissible
other teams having to wait Chris to me
this is the first break from the NFL's
very careful approach to ensure that the
same rules apply to all franchises
allowing some but not others to open and
it makes me wonder how much disparity
the NFL will tolerate as the season
approaches as the offseason unfolds and
as we get closer and closer to these
natural points where training camp where
you're gonna have training camp can't
have it at home got to go on the road
can you have fans in the stands well in
Florida you can in California you can't
how are they gonna deal with that there
are gonna be plenty of issues as the NFL
gets closer and closer into the season
as the season unfolds we'll find out how
this works but there will be disparities
and the first set of them is popping up
as of tomorrow when teams can open
facilities but according to Judy
Bautista of NFL media it's about 22 of
32 that we'll be able to which means 10
teams are gonna have a different set of
rules applied to them where they can't
fire up the engine again while the other
teams are getting that head start on
getting back to normal well either way
I'm excited it's good to have team
kind of get the get the business aspect
of things go and get people back in some
of these facilities we talked about the
memo last week I mean the guidelines as
far as keeping the building clean social
distancing within the building you know
between employees I thought were all it
was all great guidelines you know I'm
not worried about a competitive balance
yet Mike I mean even if some of the
coaches and some of these teams did get
to go into the building and others did
it yeah I think plenty of teams right
now are getting their work done with the
Xoom meetings and everything else that
way the where coaches meetings is not an
issue you know to me where this the NFL
has to be really careful here to you
know not let a competitive imbalance a
curve is anything on field wise workout
wise anything like that that would be
totally unfair to certain organizations
like you said if you're a team like the
New York Giants or Jets who are in New
Jersey right now where things not are
you know not always not hitting on all
cylinders quite yet here being so close
to New York City to where yeah it
wouldn't be fair to them if they can't
go out and work out and then yet you
know 28 teams in football er you know
having a little seven on seven or doing
walkthroughs and things like that that
would be where I'd go whoa the NFL needs
to step in and make sure this doesn't
happen any longer so you know we're not
there yet but I'm happy to see that
things are going in the right direction
or at least we're getting some people in
these buildings well I still think
though there is a necessary imbalance
though when 10 buildings remain shut
down and 22 are opening up you know you
you are allowing I mean think about the
stuff that the front office staff is
doing as it relates to preparing for the
2021 draft we've heard time and again I
mean look like the the general managers
and the scouts just shut it down they're
making plans for next year and now all
of a sudden they're gonna be in a
position where they can begin depending
upon who shows up and how many people
are allowed to be in a given facility
and they are keeping it to a limited
number but when you can reconvene at
work you can maybe be a little more
productive and maybe just yeah Chris
that a little that just that little
boost of getting a change of scenery the
idea that we've been caught in this
Groundhog Day reality for the last
two and a half months now for 22 teams
some of these front office employees
some of these Scouts are gonna get a
chance to have a change of venue and
that may energize them whereas for the
other ten teams they're still caught in
that vortex of of Sonny and Cher sing
and I got you babe it's 6:00 a.m. as
Bill Murray slams down on the alarm
clock I mean so there is an advantage
there and it's striking to me because
the NFL had been obsessed with no
advantage but there will be points where
it's unavoidable that's my point as we
go forward how many other of these
things will we see where there is gonna
be a right way table disparity and Peter
King made the point in in football
morning in America a couple of weeks ago
we're just gonna have to deal with it
right there will be unfairness there
will be things about this year that are
different than other years and you're
just gonna have to deal with it and the
teams that can deal with it are the
teams that are gonna thrive that well
that's where I wanted to say you know to
your defense or rebuttal I mean you mean
you're right I'm not trying to disagree
with you that yeah we'll bring energy to
be in the building being a team meeting
room with some employees and you get to
have a conversation about an important
topic and bounce ideas off each other
hey yeah I get that I'm with you but
it's just right now the world is not
perfect and for those other 10 teams who
can't you know get in there and have
front office people in there to have
some discussions right now and do all
that they'll live they're professionals
they'll know how to figure it out yes
it's a little less than ideal but I mean
I think that's what I was trying to get
to to basically and I just didn't say it
quite as bluntly as you were Peter King
but I think this is gonna be here where
things are not gonna be fair for all the
teams across the board I mean you might
have to be on the road for five straight
weeks or not play a home game or you
have one team you go play and they got a
crowd noise in the next week you're at
home and you have no crowd I don't know
but I know within the seriousness of
what we're going through right now
people aren't gonna want to hear some of
these players coaches NFL personnel
complain about this crap when we got 20
plus million people jobless right now
and just you know trying to live
paycheck to paycheck so that's where you
know I think you know again it's not
it's not earth breaking to me I would
get more concerned with okay now coaches
are in the building all right that's a
little
that football team oh wait this team's
got players in the building they're
doing walkthroughs and having meetings
with the players and really getting to
talk things out and the position group
meetings and all that that's when I
would go oh that's not fair to those
other ten teams they're not going to be
able to catch up or lay down the
groundwork for training camp as compared
to the teams that are in there doing
that and that's not gonna happen I think
the next big rarity will be that there
will be teams that can have a normal
training camp in the location of their
choice and there are going to be teams
who due to the pandemic have to pack up
and go somewhere else when they would
rather not do it even though over the
years plenty of teams have chosen to
pack up and go somewhere else for
training camp the trend has been stay
home for camp and they're gonna be teams
aren't gonna be able to stay home for
camp and that's gonna work a little bit
of disparity in two things and then you
touched on it and I think that this is
going to be a very real dynamic when we
get to September in October there will
be teams that have fans in the stands
there will be teams that have full
stadiums there will be teams that have
no fans present will you play games in
states where you can't have fans and it
will be an obvious disparity or do you
send those teams elsewhere and even if
you send them elsewhere who the hell is
gonna show up and cheer for those teams
it's not like they're fans right all of
them to a different state and fill the
stadium and create the crowd noise or do
you allow actual artificial crowd noise
in the stadium not to just enhance the
broadcast but in the stadium right noise
crowd noise like you have it practice to
simulate what you're gonna face on game
day to balance out that disadvantage
those are the kinds of things the NFL is
gonna have to be thinking about because
look and I understand the bigger picture
here but you know as well as anyone
Chris they love to complain they
complain about any actual or perceived
disparity because hey if nothing else
we're making an excuse for the fact that
we're gonna lose the game the best
organizations say no complaints no
excuses but there are plenty of
organizations that do complain and do
make excuses and there will be plenty of
fodder for that this see
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports